rama torch la mayor ciudad del donbass
aún bajo control ucraniano está en el
punto de mira del ejército ruso las
autoridades regionales han aconsejado a
los residentes que huyan pero nena no
quiso abandonar su mercado y ahora dice
que incluso ve a los residentes realizar
y hay que pagarle al alquiler hay que
encontrar un trabajo de dónde vamos a
sacar el dinero la gente salió los
primeros días con un poco de dinero pero
cuando no tienes nada que haces tienen
que irse porque no pueden pagar no
pueden comprar comida así que vuelven
aquí
y cuando le preguntamos deán inácio
tiene una palabra para describir la vida
en crematorios renova es una de nuestras
pensiones' son escasas hay tierra nos
bombardean continuamente mírame tengo 70
años y sigo trabajando ya no me quedan
dientes y no tengo con que comprarme
unos nuevos entre los clientes muchos
soldados esperan que su presencia sea
tranquilizadora pero también quieren
recordar las normas de seguridad
sí y también es bueno llevar un equipo
de primeros auxilios como el que veo con
usted siempre en riesgo de bombardeo por
lo que la gente tiene que ir a los
refugios cuando oyen las sirenas hay una
sensación de amenaza inminente en hama
tours que la plaza central fue atacada
el viernes y el sábado el ministro de
defensa ruso ordenó a sus ejércitos
elevar el nivel de actividad en todas
las zonas super activas de ucrania la
expulsión hizo volar las ventanas de los
edificios cercanos estos trabajadores
están reforzando las fachadas en
previsión de nuevos ataques
y aquí puedes admirar los resultados de
las supuestas últimas operaciones de
liberación de los rusos ya estamos
prácticamente en la primera línea así
que estamos preparados supongo que más
podemos hacer la vida sigue
de repente las sirenas un sonido que se
ha vuelto tan familiar en hama tours que
ya no parece importarle a mucha gente